Memory is sometimes taken for granted. But it's importance cannot be
overstated. Memory allows us to interact successfully in our world. Through
case studies such as HM, we can gain a better understanding of the areas of the
brain involved in memory. We have three types of memory. Sensory memory, which
includes iconic and echoic memory, short-term or working memory and long-term
memory. Sensory memory is very short in duration. Working memory allows for the
day to day fluidity of our actions, and long-term memory is comprised of
several types of memory. Long-term memory includes declarative memory, which
consists of episodic memory or memory for personal events. And semantic memory
which is memory for facts. In addition, we also have explicit and implicit
memories. The four steps in long term memory formation are encoding,
consolidation, storage and retrevial. We can use schemas, associative networks,
and mnemonic devices in aiding our memory efforts. Over time, we may experience
forgetting and memory loss. In addition, illness and injury can also impair our
memory. This can result from things such as Alzheimer's disease or dementia and
accidents that may result in amnesia. Some important areas of the brain
involved in memory include the cerebellum and striatum, the hippocampus and the
amygdala. Furthermore, the prefrontal cortex. Auditory cortex, visual cortex,
and somatosensory cortex all play a role in memory.